you start with the physicality of the
character and that's how you've arrived
at who the character is you start by
looking at them and that's very
important to you you look at maybe a
rendering of what the character supposed
to be like and you try and think what
what does that mean to me it was a
physical actor and how do I draw a
personality out of that yeah it's a
combination of that I mean you know it's
just like where does the character that
you're playing you know carriers tension
or pain or anger or you know aggression
let me golem it was all trapped in his
throat you know you know I mean it's
it's locating it's locating these
centers of physic for me that's that you
know certain actors like you know I put
this pair of shoes on and see if this
feels right or this jacket makes me feel
right as the character for me it's
always really a lot about about
physicality and locating that as a
central part of the psychology and the
emotion of the character if let's say
there were to be a movie one day about
myself and you know I'm no longer around
movie about not yet Conan the Barbarian
but it those relies mostly but would you
if you were just if you didn't know me
but you were just looking at pictures of
me and footage of me which I know what
you do all the time I'm sure as do all
men would you and you had to do a CGI
version of me what area I'm just curious
what would you focus on well my physique
interestingly I would say we're both
quiff led men actually I mean you know
the quip is equip is an important oh
this up here yeah okay yeah so so I
think you know that is that hair is it
is important that what you're finding
I mean you must spend like I do a little
bit of time getting yourself ready in
the morning this is this has to sit in
an oven for
and and so and because of you're very
graceful slender lithe kind of figure
and you're you're a great physics you're
a great mover by the way I mean I've
seen you move and it's pretty
spectacular
thank you I ever did that's nice I mean
I didn't think you went to that club
yeah I suppose I forget I think because
you would be motion capture motion
capture with yes but there's a lot of
them I mean I mean I think there's a lot
of that that's right to show off at a
peacock showing off it's proven that's
fantastic you've got the part
yeah you know what I'm very excited
about is there is more Oscar support now
for you know when when motion capture
first came along I think there was a
disconnect where people probably in the
Academy and people that vote for Oscars
thought we're not sure it is this does
this count what kind of acting is this
they weren't sure it takes a long time
for people to catch up and I really do
now feel that your abilities and what
you're doing and this whole new art form
that you and others like you have
created is has been recognized now it's
really exciting is I mean it's it is
great that it's finally being kind of
understood you know I mean acting is
acting and it doesn't make any
difference whether you're putting on a
costume and makeup and going on yes set
to be filmed or whether you're playing
the character and then you're having a
sort of form of digital makeup applied
to you what I do is which is what it is
so the the actual authorship of the role
the you know the playing on set right
opposite your fellow actors is it's
exactly the same price there's no
algorithm for any of that really that's
what I love
you